Chris Anderson: Bienvenido a TED.
Richard Branson: Muchas gracias. El primer TED ha sido estupendo.
CA: Has conocido a alguien interesante?
RB: Lo bueno de TED es que todo el mundo es interesante.
Estaba muy contento de ver a Goldie Hawn,
porque tenía que pedirle disculpas.
Cené con ella hace dos años y --
ella llevaba un gran anillo de boda que me probé y no lo pude sacar.
Y esa noche me fuí a casa con mi mujer
y quería saber porque llevaba otro anillo
de boda en el dedo.
Y, total, a la mañana siguiente tuvimos que ir al joyero
y cortarlo para sacarlo.
Bueno, (risas)
bueno disculpas a Goldie.
CA: Esto es muy bueno.
Vamos a poner algunas diapositivas
de algunas de tus compañías aquí.
Has empezado una o dos en tu tiempo.
Ya sabes. Virgin Atlantic, Virgin Records-
Supongo que todo empezó con una revista que se llamada Student.
Y entonces, si, todas estas otras también. Es decir, ¿como lo haces?
RB: Leí todo tipo de instrucciones de TED --
no debes hablar de tu propio negocio, y esto,
y ahora me preguntas.
Bueno supongo que no vas a ser capaz de sacarme del plató.
ya que hiciste tú la pregunta.
(Risas)
CA: Depende de cual sea la respuesta.
RB: No, es decir, creo que aprendí pronto eso de que si puedes dirigir una empresa,
realmente puedes dirigir cualquier empresa.
Es decir, todo en las empresas es encontrar la gente adecuada,
inspirar a esa gente, sabes, sacar lo mejor de la gente
y me encanta aprender y soy increíblemente curioso
y me encanta retar al status quo,
e intentar mostrar otra perspectiva.
Por tanto veo la vida como un largo proceso de aprendizaje.
Y si veo -- si vuelo en la compañía aérea de otro
y la experiencia resulta no placentera, que no lo era --
hace 21 años, entonces pensaría, bueno, quizás puedo crear
el tipo de compañía aérea en la que me gustaría volar.
Y bueno, cojí un 747 de segunda mano de Boeing y probé.
CA: Bueno eso fue una cosa rarísima.
porque tomaste esta decision que mucha gente te aconsejó era una locura.
Y de hecho, de una manera, casi acabó con tu imperio a un cierto punto.
Tuve una conversación con uno de los banqueros especialista en inversiones quien,
en aquel tiempo cuando básicamente vendiste Virgin Records
e invertiste mucho en Virgin Atlantic,
y su visión era que estas cambiando
la cuarta compañía de discos más grande del mundo
por la vigésima quinta compañía aérea más grande y que te habías vuelto loco.
¿Porqué lo hiciste?
RB: Bueno, creo que hay una línea muy fina que divide el éxito y el fracaso.
Y creo que si empiezas un negocio sin apoyo financiero,
es muy probable que vayas al lado equivocado de esa línea.
Tuvimos -- estabamos siendo atacados por British Airways;
intentaban dejar nuestra compañía aérea fuera del negocio,
y lanzaron lo que es conocido como la "campaña de las tácticas sucias".
Y me di cuenta que era probable que el imperio completo quebrara,
a menos que pusiera algo de mi parte.
Y a fin de proteger los puestos de trabajo de la gente que trabajaba para la compañía aérea,
y proteger los puestos de trabajo de la gente que trabajaba para la compañía de discos,
Tuve que vender las joyas de la familia para proteger la aerolínea.
CA: Después de Napster, pareces en realidad casi como genio,
por eso, también.
RB: Si, resultó ser el paso adecuado.
Si, en ese momento fué triste, pero seguimos adelante.
CA: Ahora, usas mucho la marca Virgin
y parece que estás obteniendo sinergia de una cosa a otra.
¿Qué representa la marca en tu cabeza?
RB: Bueno, me gusta pensar que representa calidad,
que, si alguien se topa con una compañía Virgin --
CA: Son calidad, Richard, vamos, todo el mundo habla de calidad --¿el espíritu?
RB: No, pero iba a dar un paso en esto.
Nos divertimos y creo que la gente que trabaja para ella lo pasa bien.
Nosotros, -- como digo, entramos y agitamos otras industrias
y creo, que lo hacemos de forma diferente
y creo que las industrias no son las mismas
como resultado del ataque de Virgin en el mercado.
CA: Quiero decir, hubo algunos lanzamientos donde hiciste eso --
donde quizás la marca no haya funcionado tan bien.
Quiero decir Virgin Novias- ¿que pasó ahí?
(Risas)
RB: No pudimos encontrar clientes.
(Aplauso)
CA: También tenía curiosidad porque --
Creo que perdiste una oportunidad con el lanzamiento de tus preservativos-lo lllamaste Mates (Compañeros)
Quiero decir, ¿no pudiste usar también la marca Virgin para esto?
No más Virgin, o algo así.
RB: Nuevamente, podriamos haber tendido problemas en encontrar clientes.
Quiero decir, tuvimos -- normalmente cuando lanzas una compañía y recibes reclamaciones de los clientes,
puedes encargarte de ellos.
Pero después de tres meses del lanzamiento de la compañía de preservativos
Recibí una carta, una reclamación,
y me senté y contesté a esta señora con una carta larga deshaciéndome en disculpas.
Pero obviamente no había mucho que yo pudiera hacer al respecto.
Y seis meses más tarde, o nueve meses más tarde que el problema surgiese,
Recibí esta carta encantadora con una fotografía del bebé
preguntándome si sería el padrino, que lo fui.
Bueno al final todo salió bien.
CA: ¿De verdad? Deberías haber traido una fotografía. Es maravilloso.
RB: Debería.
CA: Bueno entonces ayudanos con algunos números.
Quiero decir, ¿cuales son los números en esto?
Quiero decir,cómo de grande es el grupo en total?
Cuanto- ¿cuales son los ingresos totales?
RB:En total son 25 billones de dólares más o menos.
CA: ¿Y cuántos empleados?
RB: En torno a 55,000.
CA: Entonces has sido fotografiado de varias maneras en varias ocasiones
y nunca te has preocupado por poner tu dignidad en juego o algo parecido.
¿Qué era eso? ¿Era real?
RB:Si. Estábamos abriendo un gran almacén en Los Angleles, creo.
No. Quiero decir, creo --
CA: ¿Pero ese es tu pelo?
RB: No.
CA: ¿Que era eso?
RB: Estaba bajando a tomar el té.
CA: OK.
(Risas)
CA: Ah, esto fue muy divertido. Eso fue un fabuloso coche barco que --
RB: Ah, ese coche que nosotros- de hecho --
fue un evento de TED creo.
Eso es -- ¿puedes poner pausa es esta por un minuto?
(Risas)
RB: ¿Es un trabajo duro, no?
CA: Es decir -- es un trabajo duro.
(Risas)
Cuando vine por primera vez a América solía probar también esto con los empleados
y era una especie de -- aquí tenían diferentes reglas,
es muy extraño.
RB: Lo sé, tengo a los abogados diciéndome no debes hacer cosas como esa, pero --
CA: Quiero decir, hablando de, cuéntanos de --
RB: Pammy, nosotros lanzamos, sabes,
pensamos erróneamente que podríamos competir con Coca-Cola,
y lanzamos una botella de cola llamada "The Pammy"
y tenía la forma de Pamela Anderson.
Pero el problema es que la botella se volcaba, pero --
(Risas)
CA: ¿Diseñado quizás por Philipe Starck quizás?
RB: Por supuesto.
CA: Bueno vamos a pasar un par de fotografías más. Virgin Novias. Muy bien.
Y, OK, Para aquí. Esto fue -- ¿te dieron algún premio creo?
RB: Si, bueno, 25 años atrás lanzamos los Sex Pistols'
"Dios Salve a la Reina", y nunca esperé
que 25 años más tarde ella nos concediera un título.
Pero debe tener una memoria olvidadiza, creo
CA: Bueno, que Dios la salvo y tú tuviste tu premio.
¿Te gusta que te llamen Sir Richard, o cómo?
RB: Nunca nadie me llamó Sir Richard.
Ocasionalmente en América, oigo a la gente diciendo Sir Richard
y creo que se está llevando a cabo alguna representación de Shakespeare
Pero bueno en ningún sitio más.
CA: OK. Entonces puedes usar tu título para cualquier cosa o es sólo...
RB: No. Supongo que si tienes problemas
reservando una mesa en un restaurante o algo así,
puede valer la pena usarlo.
CA: Sabes, no es Richard Branson, es Sir Richard Branson.
RB: Haré que lo use la secretaria .
CA: OK. Bueno vamos a ver el asunto del espacio.
Creo, con nosotros, tenemos un video que muestra lo que haces
Y Virgin Galactic en el aire.
Bueno ¿Esa es la nave espacial diseñada por Bert Rutan?
RB: Sí, estará lista en -- bueno, lista en 12 meses
y luego haremos 12 meses de pruebas extensas.
y entonces de aquí a 24 meses
la gente podrá darse un viaje al espacio.
CA: ¿El interior está diseñado por Philippe Starcke?
RB: Philippe ha hecho el- si, bastante --
los logos y está construyendo la estación espacial en Nuevo Mexico,
y básicamente ha cogido un ojo
y la estación espacial será un ojo gigante,
de tal modo que cuando estés en el espacio
debes ver este enorme ojo mirándote.
Y cuando aterrices, podrás volverte hacia este ojo gigante.
Pero cuando se trata de diseño él es absolutamente un genio.
CA: ¿Pero no te hizo el diseño del motor?
RB: Philippe es bastante imprevisible,
por lo que pienso que no sería la mejor persona para diseñar el motor, no.
CA: Dió aquí una charla magnífica hace dos días.
RB: ¿Sí? No, es --
CA: Bueno, algunos le encontraron maravilloso,
algunos le encontraron estrambótico.
Sin embargo, yo personalmente le encontré maravilloso.
RB: Es un entusiasta maravilloso por eso le quiero, Pero --
CA: Bueno, ¿has tenido siempre en ti este bicho explorador?
Te has arrepentido de ello alguna vez?
RB: Muchas veces.
Quiero decir, creo que con las expediciones en globo y barco que hemos hecho en el pasado --
bueno, fui sacado del mar creo que seis veces por helicópteros, --
y cada vez no esperaba volver a casa para contarlo.
En esos momentos
desde luego que te preguntas qué estás haciendo ahí arriba o...
CA: Qué era lo más cerca que llegaste de --
cuando pensaste hasta aquí, ¿puede que sea mi punto de salida?
RB: Bueno, creo que las aventuras en globo fueron -- cada una fue --
cada una, en realidad, creo que estuvimos cerca.
Y, es decir, primero de todo fue --
nadie antes había realmente cruzado el Atlántico en un globo de aire caliente,
tuvimos que construir un globo de aire caliente que fuera capaz de volar en la corriente en chorro,
y no estábamos seguros
de que cuando un globo realmente realmente en la corriente en chorro,
si sobreviviría a vientos de 320, 360 kilómetros por hora que puedes encontrarte ahí arriba.
Y sólo el despegue inicial desde Sugarloaf para cruzar el Atlántico,
mientras íbamos entrando en la corriente en chorro, este globo enorme --
la parte de arriba del globo acabó yendo a 200 millas por hora,
la cápsula donde estábamos en la parte de abajo quizás iba a dos millas por hora,
y de repente salió disparado.
Y fue como intentar sujetar a mil caballos.
Y cruzamos todos los dedos,
rezando para que el globo se mantuviera todo junto,que, afortunadamente, lo hizo.
Pero el final de todos esos viajes en globo fue, sabes --
parecía que siempre había algo que iba mal.
y en esa ocasión en concreto estaba conmigo el aeróstata con más experiencia,
saltó y me dejó agarrado con todas mis fuerzas con mi vida en juego.
(Risas)
CA: te pidió que saltaras, o sólo dijo, "Me voy de aquí" y...
RB: No, me pidió que saltara, pero una vez que su peso ya había salido del globo,
el globo se disparó hasta los 12,000 pies y ...
CA: Y creo que con ello inspiraste la novela de Ian McEwan.
RB; Sí. No, me puse la máscara de oxígeno y me puse de pie en la parte superior del globo,
Con mi paracaídas, mirando a las nubes moviendo rápidamente por debajo,
intentando armarme de valor para saltar en el Mar del Norte, que --
y fueron momentos muy solitarios.
Pero, bueno, sobrevivimos.
CA: ¿Saltaste o -- al final descendió?
RB: Bueno, sabía que tenía media hora de combustible más o menos,
y también sabía que si saltaba las posibilidades eran que
solo tendría de vida un par de minutos restantes.
Trepé hasta volver a la cápsula y lo intenté desesperadamente
para asegurarme que estaba tomando la decisión correcta.
Y escribí algunas notas a mi familia. Y cuando trepé hacia arriba de nuevo.
miré hacia abajo a esas nubes de nuevo,
trepé para volver a la cápsula de nuevo.
Y al final pensé, existe una manera mejor.
Tengo, este globo enorme encima de mi,
es el paracaídas más grande que hay, ¿porqué no usarlo?
Y entonces conseguí que el globo volara más bajo atravesando las nubes
y cuando estaba a 50 pies, justo antes de chocar con el mar, me tiré.
Y el globo se chocó contra el mar.
y salió disparado hacia arriba sin mi 10,000 pies.
Pero fue una sensación maravillosa estar en el agua y-
CA: ¿Qué escribiste a tu familia?
RB: Lo que tú escribirías en una situación semejante,
sólo que te quiero mucho y --
ya les había escrito una carta antes de salir a este viaje, que --
sólo en caso que hubiera sucedido algo.
Pero afortunadamente no tuvieron que usarla.
CA: Estos actos heroicos han dado un valor enorme de Relaciones Públicas a tus empresas.
Los años -- y hasta que paré de ver los sondeos,
eras considerado como una especie de gran héroe en el Reino Unido y en otros lugares.
Y la gente cínica puede decir, bueno sabes, este es sólo un hombre de negocios
haciendo lo que es necesario para llevar al cabo su estilo particular de hacer marketing.
¿Cuanto de Relaciones Públicas tenía todo esto?
RB: Bueno, los expertos en Relaciones Públicas dicen que el dueño de una aerolínea,
la última cosa que debe hacer es marcharse en globos y barcos,
y estrellarse contra el mar.
(Risas)
CA: Tenían razón, Richard.
RB: De hecho,nuestra aerolínea ocupó la página completa de un anuncio en aquel tiempo para decir,
ves Richard,
hay maneras mejores de cruzar el Atlántico.
(Risas)
CA: Para hacer todo esto,
¿debes haber sido un genio desde el principio, verdad?
RB:Bueno, no te llevare la contraria en eso.
(Risas)
CA: OK, esto no es el Béisbol, OK.
CA: No -- ¿No eras una calamidad en el colegio?
RB: era disléxico, no entendía nada de los deberes.
Seguro que habría fallado los test de inteligencia (IQ).
Y fue una de las razones por las que dejé el colegio cuando tenía 15 años.
Y si -- si no estoy interesado en algo, no lo capto.
Para alguien que es disléxico,
también vives situaciones un tanto raras.
Quiero decir, por ejemplo, tuve que -- sabes,
He estado dirigiendo el grupo más grande de compañías privadas de Europa,
pero no he sido capaz de saber la diferencia entre neto y bruto.
Y bueno las reuniones de la junta directiva han estado fascinante.
(Risas)
Y es como, ¿buenas noticias o malas noticias?
Y la gente normalmente diría, oh, entonces son malas noticias.
CA: Sólo para aclarar, los 25 billones es bruto, verdad, esto es bruto?
(Risas)
RB: Bueno, en realidad espero que sea neto, teniendo --
He acertado.
CA: No, confía en mi, es bruto.
(Risas)
RB: Cuando cumplí los 50 alguien me llevó a la sala de juntas y me dijo,
"Mira Richard, aquí hay un -- déjame dibujarte un diagrama --
Aquí hay una red en el mar,
y el pez ha sido arrastrado del mar a la red.
Y lo que te queda en esta pequeña red son los beneficios que tienes,
todo lo demás ha sido comido".
Y al final lo entendí.
(Risas)
(Aplauso)
CA: Pero, quiero decir. en el colegio, -- ademas de estar --
sabes, de manera lamentable académicamente hablando,
sin embargo eras el capitán de los equipos de criquet y fútbol,
eras una especie de -- eras un líder natural,
pero un poco -- eras un rebelde entonces, o cómo...
RB: Sí, creo que era un poco inconformista -- pero -- y era,
si, afortunadamente era bueno en el deporte
y al menos destacaba en algo, en el colegio.
CA: Y anterior a eso ocurrieron algunas cosas raras en tu vida.
Quiero decir, hay una historia de tu madre
que supuestamente te tiró a un campo, a la edad de cuatro años, y te dijo "Ok, camina a casa".
¿Pasó esto de verdad?
RB: Era, sabes,
creía que teníamos que ser independientes desde pequeños.
Bueno nos hizo cosas, por las que ahora sería arrestada.
tales como empujarnos fuera del coche,
y mandarnos encontrar solos el camino a casa de la abuela,
dejándonos más o menos cinco millas antes de llegar.
Y nos hacía ir a dar unas estupendas y largas vueltas en bici.
Y no nos dejaba ver televisión .
CA: ¿Pero hay un riesgo en eso?
Hay mucha gente en la sala que son ricos, y tienen niños,
y tenemos este dilema de como educarlos.
Miras a la generación de niños que vienen en la actualidad y piensas
están demasiado mimados, no saben lo que tienen,
vamos a criar una generación de privilegiados...
RB: No, creo que si vas a educar niños,
lo único que quieres es colmarlos de amor y elogios y entusiasmo.
No creo que puedas mimar a tus hijos demasiado sinceramente.
CA: Tú no has salido demasiado malo, he de decir,
El director de tu colegio te dijo --
El creía que eras como una especie de enigma en tu colegio --
dijo, que ibas a ser un millonario o ir a la cárcel,
y no estoy segura de cual.
¿Cual de ellas ocurrió primero?
(Risas)
RB: Bueno, he hecho ambas. Creo que estuve antes en la cárcel.
Realmente fui procesado en el Reino Unido por dos leyes bastante antiguas.
Fui procesado bajo la Ley de 1889 de Enfermedades Venéreas.
y la Ley de 1916 de Anuncios Indecentes.
La primera vez por mencionar la palabra enfermedad venérea en publico, que --
teníamos un centro dónde ayudábamos a los jóvenes que tenían problemas.
Y uno de los problemas que tienen los jóvenes es la enfermedad venérea.
Y hay una ley antigua que dice
no puedes mencionar la palabra enfermedad venérea o escribirlo en público.
Entonces la policía llamó a la puerta, y nos avisó que nos iba a arrestar
si continuábamos mencionando la palabra enfermedad venérea.
Lo cambiamos por enfermedades sociales.
y la gente venía con acné y espinillas,
pero no venía nadie más con enfermedades venéreas.
Entonces volvimos a poner Enfermedades Venéreas y fuimos arrestados.
Y posteriormente, "No importan las estupideces (Bollocks), aquí están los Sex Pistols",
la policía decidió que la palabra "estupideces", era una palabra grosera y fuimos arrestados
por usar la palabra "estupideces" en el álbum de los Sex Pistols.
Y el dramaturgo, John Morimer, nos defendió.
Y nos preguntó si podíamos encontrar un experto en lingüística
para proponer una definición distinta de la palabra estupideces.
Y entonces llamé a la Universidad de Nottingham,
y pedí hablar con el profesor de lingüística,
Y dijo "Mira, estupideces (Bollocks) no es -- no tiene en absoluto nada que ver con bolas.
Realmente es un apodo que se les ha dado a los sacerdotes en el siglo XVIII".
(Risas)
Y prosiguió, " Es más yo mismo soy un sacerdote".
Y entonces le dije, ¿"Le importaría venir a declarar al juzgado"?
Y dijo que estaría encantado. Y le dije --
y dijo, "¿Quiere que lleve el alzacuellos?
Y le dije, "Si, sería -- por favor..."
(Risas)
CA: Es genial.
RB: Entonces nuestro testigo principal fue -- defendió que realmente era
"No importa el Sacerdote, Aquí están los Sex Pistols"
(Risas)
Y el juez nos declaró -- a su pesar nos declaró no culpables, --
CA: Es escandaloso.
(Aplauso)
Ahora en serio, ¿hay un lado oscuro?
Mucha gente diría que es imposible
que alguien pueda reunir esta increíble colección de empresas
sin acuchillar por la espalda a unos cuantos,
saber, hacer algunas cosas feas,
Has sido acusado de ser despiadado.
Había una biografía escrita sobre ti un tanto desagradable.
¿Es algo de esto verdad? ¿Hay alguna parte verdad en esto?
RB: Realmente no creo que el estereotipo
de un hombre de negocios sea pisotear a la gente para llegar arriba,
hablando en términos generales, funciona.
Creo que si tratas a la gente bien,
la gente volverá y volverá en busca de más.
Y creo que tu reputación es lo que tienes en la vida
y el mundo es muy pequeño.
Y realmente creo que la mejor manera
de convertirte en un líder de los negocios con éxito, es tratar a la gente bien y de forma justa,
y me gusta pensar que así es como dirigimos Virgin.
CA:Y que ocurre con la gente que te quiere y que te ve gastando --
te mantienes enganchado a estos nuevos proyectos,
pero casi parece que estás adicto al lanzamiento de cosas nuevas.
¿Te entusiasma una idea, y ala!
Quiero decir, ¿piensas en el equilibrio en la vida?
¿Cómo se siente tu familia
cada vez que das un paso hacia algo nuevo y grande?
RB: También creo que ser padre es muy importante,
desde que los niños eran muy pequeños,
sabes, cuando se van de vacaciones me voy con ellos.
Y lo pasamos muy bien los tres meses más o menos que pasamos fuera juntos.
Si, sabes, estaré en contacto. Tenemos mucha suerte,
tenemos esta pequeña isla en el Caribe y podemos --
les puedo llevar allí y podemos traer amigos,
y podemos jugar juntos,
pero puedo también estar al tanto de lo que ocurre con los negocios.
CA: Empezaste a hablar hace pocos años
del término filantropía capitalista.
¿Qué es esto?
RB: Ha sido probado que el capitalismo es un sistema que funciona.
Sabes, la alternativa, es el comunismo, que no ha funcionado.
Pero el problema con el capitalismo es que
la riqueza extrema acaba en manos de una poca gente,
y por lo tanto creo que, la responsabilidad extrema va con esa riqueza.
Y creo que es importante que los individuos,
que están en esa posición afortunada, no acaben compitiendo
por barcos más y más grandes y por coches más y más grandes.
pero más bien, usar el dinero para bien crear nuevos puestos de trabajo
o tratar asuntos alrededor del mundo,
CA: Y cuales son los asuntos que más te preocupan, a los que más te dedicas,
¿hacia los que quieres destinar tus recursos?
RB: Bueno, hay -- Existen muchos temas.
El calentamiento global es desde luego una amenaza enorme para la humanidad.
y estamos poniendo mucho tiempo y energía en ello
A, intentar sacar combustibles alternativos
y B, acabamos de lanzar este premio, que es un premio de verdad
en caso de que no obtengamos respuesta acerca de los combustibles alternativos,
en caso de que no consigamos que las emisiones de carbono
desciendan rápidamente y en caso de que lleguemos a una situación límite,
necesitamos animar a la gente a que busque una manera
de extraer carbono de la atmósfera de la tierra.
Y nosotros sólo -- sabes, en realidad no había gente
trabajando en eso antes, por eso queríamos que la gente lo intentara --
que todos los mejores cerebros del mundo empezaran a pensar en ello,
y también intentar extraer el metano
también de la atmósfera de la tierra.
Y en efecto tuvimos en torno a 15,000 formularios rellenados
diciendo que quieren probar.
Y sólo necesitamos uno, por tanto tenemos esperanza.
CA: ¿Y también trabajas en Africa en un par de proyectos?
RB: Sí, tenemos -- estamos montando algo llamado
la habitación de guerra, que quizás es la palabra incorrecta --
estamos intentando --- quizás lo cambiaremos -- pero de todas formas, es la habitación de guerra
para tratar de coordinar todo el ataque que se está llevando a cabo en Africa,
todos los problemas sociales diferentes que hay en Africa
e intentar llevar a cabo las mejores prácticas.
Entonces, por ejemplo,
hay un doctor en Africa que descubrió que
si a una madre que está embarazada de 24 semanas le das medicamentos antirretrovirales
el bebé no tendrá VIH cuando nazca.
Y entonces si esa información se reparte al --
resto de Africa es importante.
CA: La habitación de guerra suena, suena muy fuerte y dramático.
Y existe el riesgo de que la especie de héroes de negocios del Oeste
se entusiasmen tanto que -- Quiero decir, están acostumbrados a tener una idea,
y dejar las cosas hechas, y creen profundamente
en su habilidad por marcar una diferencia en el mundo.
Existe el riesgo de que vayamos a sitios como Africa y digamos,
tenemos que solucionar este problema y lo podemos hacer,
Tengo estos billones de dólares, y sabes, la,la,la --
aquí está la gran idea. Y coger una especie de situación mucho más compleja
y en realidad acabar convirtiéndolo en una situación más difícil. ¿Te preocupa esto?
RB: Bueno, primero que todo en esta situación en particular, estamos en realidad --
estamos trabajando con el gobierno en ello.
Quiero decir, Thabo Mbeki tuvo sus problemas en aceptar
que VIH y SIDA están relacionados, pero es el camino, creo,
de que él aborde este problema y en lugar de que el mundo le critique
es una manera de trabajar con él, con su gobierno.
Es importante que si la gente va a Africa e intenta ayudar,
que no vaya y simplemente abandone pasados unos años.
Tiene que ser consecuente.
Pero creo que los líderes de los negocios pueden traer su conocimiento empresarial
y ayudar a los gobiernos a que enfoquen las cosas de manera algo distinta.
Por ejemplo, estamos montando clínicas en Africa.
donde vamos a dar
medicamentos antirretrovirales gratis, tratamiento gratis de tuberculosis
y tratamiento gratis de malaria.
Pero también intentamos hacer las clínicas autosostenibles
de tal modo que la gente pague por otros aspectos.
CA: Es decir, mucha gente cínica opina de alguien como tú o Bill Gates
en realidad es -- lo que os lleva a hacerlo
es un cierto deseo, de dar buena imagen,
para evitar la sensación de culpa y no como un instinto real filantrópico.
¿Qué les dirías?
RB: Bueno, creo que todo el mundo --
la gente hace cosas por una variedad de distintas razones
y creo que, sabes, cuando esté en mi lecho de muerte
Querré sentir que he marcado una diferencia
en la vida de otras personas.
Y puede que sea egoísta pensar así,
pero es la manera en la que he sido educado.
Creo que si estoy en la posición
de poder cambiar radicalmente la vida de otras personas para mejor,
Debo hacerlo.
CA: ¿Cuantos años tienes?
RB: Tengo 56.
CA: El psicólogo Erik Erikson dice que, como yo le entiendo
y soy un total aficionado, pero la gente al cumplir los treinta, los cuarenta les mueve
este deseo de crecer y es cuando llegan a sentirse realizados.
los 50, 60. el modo de operar cambia a la cuestión de sabiduría
y la búsqueda de legado.
Es decir, parece que tú estás aun
un poco en la fase de crecimiento,
aún estás haciendo estos increíbles planes nuevos.
¿Cuanto piensas en el legado,
y que te gustaría que fuera tu legado?
RB: No creo que piense mucho en el legado.
Es decir, me gusta -- sabes, mi abuela vivió hasta los 101,
con un poco de suerte tengo otros 30 o 40 años por delante.
No, sólo quiero vivir la vida de forma plena.
Si puedo marcar una diferencia,
espero poder marcar una diferencia.
Y en este momento una de las cosas positivas es que
tienes a Sergey y Larry de Google, por ejemplo,
que son buenos amigos.
Y, gracias a Dios, tienes dos personas
que se preocupan genuinamente por el mundo y con este tipo de riqueza.
Si tuvieran este tipo de riqueza y no les importara el mundo,
sería muy preocupante.
Y van a marcar una gran diferencia al mundo.
Y creo que es importante
que la gente que está en esa posición marque una diferencia.
CA: Bueno, Richard, cuando estaba empezando en el negocio
no sabía nada de esto y también estaba como una especie de --
Pensaba que la gente de negocios tenía que ser despiadada
y que era esta la única manera en la que tendrías la posibilidad de tener éxito.
Y realmente tú me inspiraste. Te miré, y pensé,
bueno, el lo ha logrado, quizás hay una manera distinta.
Por tanto me gustaría darte las gracias por esa inspiración
y por venir hoy a TED. Gracias.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplauso)